السلام عليكم ورحمه الله واهلا بكم ارتفعت
وتيره المعارك بين الجيش اللبناني ومسلحين
اسلاميين معارضين للنظام السوري في بلده
عرسال اقصى شرق لبنان وازدادت حده وعنفا
اسفرت المواجهات التي بدات امس عن سقوط
قتلى وجرحى من الطرفين بالاضافه الى
مدنيين اغلبهم من اللاجئين السوريين في
البلده والذين يقدر عددهم بعشرات الالاف
ويعيشون ظروفا انسانيه صعبه نتوقف مع هذا
الخبر لنناقش في محورين ما هي خلفيات هذه
المواجهات بين الجيش اللبناني والمسلحين
في عرسال وما هي تداعيات ذلك على
البلاد وهل بدا لبنان بتسديد ضريب انخراط
بعض القوى عسكريا في سوريا ام ان خطر
الجماعات المتطرفه يتمدد في دول
المنطقه كانت الاشتباكات قد اندلعت عقب
توقيف الجيش اللبناني لقائد لواء فجر
الاسلام السوري عماد جمعه الذي قد اعلن
الذي اعلن بيعته لتنظيم الدوله الاسلاميه
وقد القت هذه التطورات بظلالها على المشهد
السياسي اللبناني بين من يتهم حزب الله
بجلب التطرف والارهاب الى لبنان بسبب
انخراطه العسكري في سوريا وبين من يعتبر
ان خطر تنظيم الدوله الاسلاميه ومن يوصفون
بتكفيري يتمدد في دول
المنطقه عرسال بلده لبنانيه في مهب الرياح
السوريه تعصف بعرسال الان اسوا التوترات
الامنيه منذ اندلاع الثوره عند الجار
القريب جدا بدا كل شيء باعتقال عماد جمعه
انه من قاده لواء فجر الاسلام السوري
المعارض الذي بايع تنظيم الدوله الاسلاميه
منذ اسابيع كان توقيف جمعه عند حاجز للجيش
اللبناني في جرود عرسال كافيا ليفجر
المواجهات الاعنف بين مسلحين تدفقوا من
سوريا والجيش اللبناني وجد هذا الجيش نفسه
على حين غره في عين العاصفه كلفه ذلك مقتل
ما لا يقل عن عشره من جنوده فقد 13 وقعوا
على الارجح في اسر المسلحين وتلك تطورات
تفرض سؤالا لا مفر منه لماذا الان يستغرب
السائلون توقيف عماد جمعه خلال ادخاله
جريحا سوريا الى عرسال اصيب في معارك جرود
القلمون ضد حزب الله اللبناني فقد كان
الرجل يوصي بعدم الاحتكاك مع الجيش
اللبناني وكان يعور حواجزه دون مشاكل لكن
قياده الجيش لبناني تضع توقيفه ضمن مخطط
هجومي معد سلفا تفاخر بانها
احبطت في المقابل يتساءل ساسه ومحللون عمن
من مصلحته الزج بالجيش اللبناني في صراع
يرونه غير محمود
العواقب يتحدث البعض عم يوصفون باصحاب
الطموحات الفرديه ومعهم اصحاب المغامرات
المرتبطه بالمشاريع
الاقليميه اشارات يفهمها اللبنانيون تشبه
تلك القائله ان عرسال تدفع ثمن وقوفها مع
الشعب السوري في ثورته ومحنته واليوم
عرسال نفسها في محنه البلده ذات الغالبيه
السنيه التي تؤوي اكثر من 100 الف لاجئ
سوري تشهد حركه نزوح كثيفه فرارا من القصف
قصف يعتقد ناشطون سوريون في عرسال ان لحزب
الله يدا فيه لا يعلق حزب الله لكنه يؤكد
وفه صفا واحدا مع الجيش في مواجهه المخاطر
المحدقه بلبنان ولعلها المخاطر ذاتها التي
راها الحزب قبلا في القصير ثم يبرود في
الجانب السوري من
الحدود موضوع حلقتنا هذه نناقشه مع ضيوفنا
من بيروت مع كل من الدكتور عماد الحوت
النائب في البرلمان اللبناني عن الجماعه
الاسلاميه وواصف عواضه الكاتب والباحث
السياسي والعميد الياس حنا الخبير في
الشؤون العسكريه والاستراتيجيه نرحب
بضيوفنا الكرام سيد واصف عواضه لماذا او
بدايه ما الذي جرى حقيقه في عرسان ولماذا
تقرر مواجهه هذه الجماعات المسلحه الان
بالتحديد يعني ما حصل في الحقيقه كان
متوقعا لم يكن مفاجئا لاحد هذه الاحداث
التي تحصل اليوم له لها خلفياتها ولها
اسبابها ولعل السبب
الاول ان هذا التجمع الذي حصل
للمسلحين في جرود عرسال وجرود القلمون بعد
معارك القلمون كان لابد ان ينفجر يوما ما
لذلك لا يمكن ان تضع النار الى جانب
البارود وتبقى الامور مستقره ولكن وج وجود
هذه الجماعات المسلحه في عرسال كان معروفا
يعني وجوده منذ مده وليس شيء جديد لماذا
الان نعم هذا هذا صحيح هذا صحيح يعني
لماذا لا يكون غدا ولماذا لا يكون قبل
ايام ليس التوقيت هو المهم ولكن المهم ان
كل الظروف الموضوعيه والظروف الذاتيه قد
تهيات لمثل هذه المعركه ربما كانت الشراره
في اعتقال عماد جمعه من قبل حاجز الجيش
اللبناني ولكن الغريب ان جبهه النصره تقول
ان عماد جمعه لا يعنيها وهو تابع الى
تنظيم داعش لماذا اذا هذا الهجوم على
الجيش اللبناني طالما هذا الموقوف لا يعني
جبهه النصره اذا الموضوع ان هذه العمليه
كانت متوقعه ولم تكن مفاجئه لان ما يحصل
في جرود عرسال وفي جرود القلمون كان لابد
ان يصل الى هذه النتيجه التي نراها اليوم
استاذ عماد الح الحوت كيف تنظر الى
الاشتباكات الجاريه الان بين الجيش
اللبناني وهذه الجماعات المسلحه في عرسال
وعلى اي خلفيه
برايك يعني بدايه اسمح لي ان اوجه التحيه
لاهالي عرسال الذين امتزج دمهم بدم الجيش
اللبناني والقوى الامنيه المختلفه ما يحصل
في عرسال لا نستطيع ان نفصله عن سياق
موجود في هذه المنطقه من فتره القلمون
الغربي منطقه من اكثر من اسبوعين الان في
عمليه استنزاف يومي لحزب الله ولجيش
النظام من خلال
عمليات الثوار في سوريا انا اعتقد انه ما
يحصل اليوم في عرسال له هدفان الهدف الاول
محاوله استدراج الجيش لهذه المعركه من
خلال مواجهه مع المجموعات المسلحه طبعا
الذي التي ننكر ان تهاجم الجي نستنكر ان
تهاجم الجيش باي حال من الاحوال والهدف
الثاني هو تخفيف الضغط عن حزب الله الذي
يستنزف في هذه المنطقه من خلال اشراك
الجيش هذا وا الهاء الثوار لانه في نهايه
الامر الثوار في في في المنطقه اهلهم في
عرسال والان ما يحصل سيجعل الثوار غير
قادرين على التركيز في معركتهم مع النظام
في سوريا وسيكونوا اكثر انشغالا بتامين
الامن والاستقرار لاهلهم لاهلهم نعم ولكن
من يريد ان يستدرج الجيش الى هذه المواجهه
تقول يراد استدراج الجيش من انا انا
باعتقادي من كان مستنزف اي النظام السوري
ومن يعاونه في هذه المنطقه هو الذي يريد
استدراج الجيش حتى يدفع الفاتوره نيابه
عنه لذلك الان الاولويه الملحه ان نقف مع
الجيش في عمليه بسط نفوذ الدوله في عرسال
وان نمنع ان يستدرج هذا الجيش الى معركه
الاخرين وان يكون بديلا للاخرين في
معاركهم سيد الياس حنا هل تتفق مع هذه
القراءه انا اقول اليوم لن يعني سوف لن
ادخل في موضوع الاتهام والاتهام المبادل
ونظريه المؤامره انا اقول اليوم واقع رزال
الجغرافي والتماس مع الجغرافيا جغرافيه
العنف في القلمون وبالتالي تركيبه عرسال
المذهبيه في محيط يسيطر عليه حزب الله
اليوم في مرحلتين يعني مرحله معارك
القلمون
الاساسيه المرحله الثانيه هي
مرحله الدوله الاسلاميه في العراق وانسحاب
عصائب اهل الحق من محيط او من ريف دمشق
وبالتالي عوده عمليه الكر والفر و وحرب
العصابات في منطقه القلمون التي اتت الى
موضوع القتلى من حزب الله واستنزاف حزب
الله اليوم تعتبر عرسال هي الملاز الامن
لهؤلاء الذين يقاتلون حزب الله وبالطبيعة
يعني افسر لماذا محرج الجيش اليوم في هذه
المرحله هلا قد يستفيد منها حزب الله ولكن
في المعنى الاساسي هناك ديناميه هي اكبر
من لبنان هي اكبر من حزب الله وحتى اكبر
من موضوع المعارضه في سوريا فاذا هذا امر
طبيعي ان تقطع الملاذ الامن المستشفيات
الميدانيه وبالتالي الذهاب الى الاهالي
اهاليهم في منطقه عرسال حتى هناك عده يعني
انتماءات يعني هناك داعش هناك جبهه النص ص
هناك تنظيمات مختلفه هذا الامر ادى في وقت
من الاوقات وهذه ليست المره الاولى مع
الجيش هي تكرار لحوادث يعني مستمره مع
الجيش وكان هذا الانفجار منتظر في مرحله
من المراحل اتى اليوم طيب ولكن نريد ان
افهم اكثر يعني هل معنى ذلك ان هناك تفاهم
او تنسيق بين الجيش وجه ما في سوريا
للتضييق على هذه الجماعات المسلحه حتى لا
تدخل او تجد لها ملاذا امنا كما اعتادت في
عرسال ويتم تضييقه عليها في الارض السوريه
و والتعاطي معها عسكريا
هناك اذا اخذنا العقل الدولي العقل الدوله
او عقل الجيش في مكان ما بمعزل عن حزب
الله هذه الجماعات كانت ممرا لتفجيرات
داخل ال داخل لبنان وهذا امر بالمطلق
يعتبر تهديدا للامن القومي هلا هناك تقاطع
مصالح في مكان ما انا ليس لدي معلومات اذا
كان هناك تنسيق امني في مكان ما ولكن ما
يوحي به اليوم وهذا تحدث عنه سعاده النائب
انه الاستنزاف لحزب الله والحشره او
الماذق الذي دخل فيه النظام لانه اليوم
هذه المنطقه تعتبر الخلفيه الاساسيه
الاستراتيجيه او العمق الاستراتيجي
للعاصمه هذا الامر قد يساهم يستفيد منه
حزب الله وحتى النظام في سوريا ولكن في
نفس الوقت ما يقوم به الجيش هو من ضمن
مهماته الاساسيه وهذا ما تحدث عنه النائب
عندما قال انه نحن مع الجيش ضد هذا
الموضوع وضد تدخل حزب الله في سوريا هلا
اليوم تدخل حزب الله في سوريا هو احدى
الاسباب وليست كل الاسباب لما يجري في
لبنان طيب سيد واصف
عواده قلت قبل قليل بان التوقيت ليس مهم
هناك من يطرحه بان التوقيت مهم لربما لان
الرجل هذا الذي اعتقل عماد جمعه واصبح
مطلوبا الان كان يمر عبر مختلف الحواجز
الامنيه وعسكريه في فترات سابقه دون ان
يتم يتم توقيفه لماذا الان يتم
توقيفه يعني انا هذا هذا هذا الخبر لا
اعتقد انه مثبت و وصحيح عماد جمعه رجل
مطلوب من الاساس لدى الدوله اللبنانيه كما
كل اعضاء جبهه النصره وداعش و وغيرهم لا
شك ان الجيش
اللبناني اكتشف هذه المره هذا الرجل او
انه ربما للمره الاولى يمر على هذه
الحواجز لا اعتقد يعني هذا الكلام وفي كل
الاحوال على كل حال يعني هذه
نظريه المؤامره اصبحت جدلا عقيما بالنسبه
لنا نحن اللبنانيين بسبب خلافاتنا بسبب
خلافاتنا السياسيه الداخليه الان سؤال اخر
يتعلق بموضوع تدخل الجيش الان هناك عدد من
من جنود قتلوا واخرون فقدوا هناك من يسال
الم يكن ربم ربما الاجدى ان يتم التعامل
مع الموضوع باسلوب اخر بشكل اخر ي يجنب
لبنان تبعات ما جرى وما قد ياتي
لاحقا يعني لا اعرف كيف كان يمكن للجيش
اللبناني الموجود له ثكنه عسكريه وموجود
له عده حواجز على الحدود ان يتعامل
بالحسنى واللين مع مسلحين جاؤوا من اراضي
من الاراضي السوريه وهم ليسوا لبنانيين
وبالتالي لا يشك
اي شرعيه كيف يمكن للجيش اللبناني ان كان
يتعامل معهم بطريقه الحسنى واللين ولكن
الان ما اريد وكن في السابق جرت تسويات
كثيره في في احداث مماثله كانت هناك احداث
مماثله وجرت تسويات جنبت يعني لبنان سقوط
عدد من القتلى والجرحى
احداث احداث مع مسلحين سوريين دخلوا
الاراضي اللبنانيه لا اعتق ليس المقصود
هنا بالمسلحين السوريين بالتحديد او من
جنسيات اخرى ولكن نعم في احداث امنيه
مشابهه نعم نعم نعم هذا حصل يعني في بعض
الاحيان مع بعض المسلحين
اللبنانيين او الذين ينتسبون الى المقاومه
او الذين ينتسبون الى مسلحين في طرابلس او
او غير ذلك ولكن مسلحين موجودين اتوا من
خارج الاراضي اللبنانيه لم يتعامل الجيش
اللبناني مره واحده معهم باللين والحسنى
وبترك الامور على عواهنها ما اريد ان
اقوله الان بكل صراحه ان هذا الجدل العقيم
هذا الجدل العقيم لن يوصل الى نتيجه انا
انصح اللبنانيين جميعا كل فرقاهم بالوقوف
وراء الجيش اللبناني لحصر هذه المعركه على
الاقل ومنع امتدادها الى كل الاراضي
اللبنانيه لان الضرر ساعه اذ سيلحق عماد
الحوت ما يفهم كلامك ان لبنان بات لربما
يواجه خطر مسلحي تنظيم الدوله الاسلاميه
على غرار العراق وسوريا هل تتفق مع ذلك
السيد عماد
الحوت اولا دعني يؤكد انه الجيش ليس بموقع
المتهم من الطبيعي للجيش عندما يهاجم
وتهاجم حواجزه ان يرد على على الاعتداء
بما يتناسب مع حجم الاعتداء وبالتالي لا
احد يضع الجيش في موقع الاتهام في هذه
القضيه انا اقول ان الجيش هو في موقع
الاستدراج لان يستنزف كما استنزفت قوى
اخرى في هذه المنطقه وهذا ما ينبغي ان
نحصن الجيش من الوقوع فيه بشكل او باخر
بالتعاون معه طبعا الامر الثاني الحقيقه
محاوله تصوير الوضع وكانه يعني داعش الان
في حاله تمدد باتجاه لبنان دعنا نتذكر انه
لم يكن هناك اي تهديد للبنان قبل تدخل حزب
الله في سوريا وان هذا التدخل في سوريا هو
الذي استدرج هذه الافعال الى لبنان
وبالتالي اذا نحن اردنا ان نجد ح حل جذري
لهذا الموضوع ينبغي ان يكون هناك امران
الامر الاول هو ان يتوقف حزب الله عن
التدخل في سوريا والعراق واستدراج هذه
الحالات العنف الى لبنان وان يقوم الجيش
اللبناني وان نساعده على اداء دوره باقفال
الحدود بالاتجاهين يعني منع اي متدخل من
الاراضي السوريه في لبنان واي متدخل من
الاراضي اللبنانيه من اللبنانيين في سوريا
عندها نكون وضعنا حد حقيقي لاي خطر يتهدد
الواقع اللبناني طيب سي العميد يس حنا
يعني ما فهم من كلامك في البدايه ان ما
يجري في عرسال هو امتداد لمعركه
القلمون او احد نتائجها ولكن كيف يمكن
احتواء ما يجري الان في ارسال هذه
الاشتباكات دون ان تكون لها تداعيات اخطر
على لبنان وان يكون هناك امتداد جغرافي
لهذه
المواجهات في الداخل اللبناني طبعا انا
اقول اليوم انه واقع الجيش هو واقع حساس
جدا لانه مكونات البلد موجوده واليوم
خلينا نكون واقعيين يعني السنه يعتبرون
اليوم في لبنان انهم مستهدفين والجيش يقوم
بماء كما حصل في صيدا وهذا امر يتطلب اي
غطاء سياسي اساسي يعني اليوم في عند السنه
الاخوان السنه في لبنان هناك مواقف متعدده
من الجيش اليوم راينا ما حدث يعني بطرابلس
القرار من التجمع الاسلامي او التجمع
الطرابلسي لها حساسيه عن هذا الموضوع حتى
الجيش يقال عنه في صيدا وحتى اليومم تجمع
بطرابلس البيان الذي صدر هذا امر يدل انه
في حساسيه معينه خاصه انه الجيش بتركيبته
هي تركيبه مذهبيه وهذا امر يضع اعباء
كثيره على الجيش يجب ان يكون هناك تغطيه
سياسيه اساسيه لموضوع انها هذا الاشتباك
لانه معركه عرسال معركه صعبه جدا ولا
اعتقد انه سيكون هناك معركه خاصه داخل
بلده عرسال لانه هذا الامر يتطلب غطاء
سياسيا وخاصه خاصه من السنه في لبنان
لانهم مكون اساسي ومهم في هذه التركيبه
شكرا لك العميد الياس حنان الخبير في
الشؤون العسكريه
والاستراتيجيه نحن بعد الفاصل مشاهدنا
الكرام سنناقش تداعيات المواجهات بين
الجيش اللبناني والمسلحين في عرسال نرجو
ان تبقوا
معنا اهلا بكم من جديد مشاهدينا الكرام في
هذه الحلقه التي تناقش خلفيات وتداعيات
المواجهات بين الجيش اللبناني والمسلحين
في عرسال اي سيد واصف عواضه الى اي حد
ربما ما يجري في عرسال الان
قد يطرح على الطاوله ملف اللاجئين
السوريين في لبنان
و ربما اعاده النظر في هذا الملف حتى لا
تكون
هذه المنطقه بؤره يمكن من خلالها ان تتسلل
جماعات
مسلحه متطرفه الى الداخل اللبناني وتخلط
الاوراق كلها
نعم هذا صحيح ملف اللاجئين السوريين مطروح
من الاساس على بساط البحث امام اللبنانيين
لكنه لم يصل الى نتيجه وليس له حل واعتقد
ان مجلس الوزراء اللبناني غدا سيناقش ايضا
هذا الموضوع ولكن لا حل لهذا الموضوع
هنالك مليون ونصف مليون سوري في لبنان
يتوزعون على كامل الاراضي اللبنانيه ما من
حلول له هذه المشكله الحل الوحيد هو ان
يستقر الوضع في سوريا ويعود اللاجئون
السوريون الى سوريا ربما يتم التخفيف من
هذه الازمه ولكن ليست لدى الدوله
اللبنانيه القدرات على معالجه هذه المشكله
لذلك اعتقد ان هذه المشكله س وجود
اللاجئين السوريين سيفرق المزيد من بؤر
التوتر كما حصل في منطقه عرسال كل ما
علينا ان نقوم به كلبنانيين هو ان نتفادى
المشاكل الداخليه والخلافات الداخليه
والصراعات الداخليه السياسيه التي تؤدي
الى توتير وتصعيد هذه المشكله وليس التي
ليس لها حل قريب للاسف الشديد نعم سيد
عماد الحوت قبل ان يغادرنا العميد الياس
حنا كان يقول بان معركه عرسال هي معركه
صعبه وتتطلب غطاء سياسيا من كل القوه في
الداخل اللبناني لمواجهه خطر ما قد يتهدد
لبنان باسره وليس فقط تيارا دون اخر كيف
يمكن لربما التعامل مع ما يجري مع ارسال
بدون تجاذبات وحسابات سياسيه بين القوه
السياسيه في
لبنان اولا دعني اؤكد انه ليس هناك اختلاف
الموقف من الجيش اللبناني الجيش اللبناني
هو مؤسسه من مؤسسات الدوله التي نحرص
عليها و
الناها فاعتقد انه هذه النقطه ليست موقع
نقاش اما الازمه في سوريا في في عرسال
الان كيف نستطيع ان نتجاوزها انا اعتقد
فعلا انه اذا اذا الجيش دخل في معركه
مفتوحه في عرسال هذا سيؤدي الى استنزاف
طويل والى ازدياد في التوتر المطلوب الان
كما حصل الان الان في وقف اطلاق نار
لاتاحه المجال لتجنيب المدنيين القصف
وتجنيب الاحياء السكنيه في ارسال القصف ا
ترك المجال للمسلحين السوريين ان يخرجوا
من عرسال ويغادر الاراضي اللبنانيه لانه
لا يصح ان يبقى اي مسلح خارج الاطر
الشرعيه اللبنانيه على الاراضي اللبنانيه
ان نستعيد طبعا الافراد من عناصر الجيش
والقوى الامنيه المفقودين وان تعود سلطه
الدوله من خلال الجيش والقيه والامنيه الى
عرسال كما كانت قبل هذا الحدث لانه قبل
هذا الحدث كانت حواجز الجيش وقوى الامن
منتشره في عرسال كاي منطقه اخرى من لبنان
ه يمكن ن هل يمكن ان يتم معالجه هذا
الموقف كما سالت قبل قليل دون موقف موحد
من القوى السياسيه ودون النظر الى حسابات
لربما وخلافات بين هذه الاطراف المكون
المشهد السياسي في
لبنان على العكس تماما لانه هناك موقف
موحد الان لتجنيب الجيش هذا المازق نحن
نستطيع ان ان ننطلق من هذا الموقف لنصل
الى تحقيق هذه
النقاط الفصائل الثوار السوريين عبر عن
رغبتهم في مغادره الاراضي
اللبنانيه ووقف هذا هذه المعركه العبثيه
التي لا تفيد احد طيب سيد واصف عواض قلت
قبل قليل بان الملف ملف الوجود وجود
اللاجئين السوريين في لبنان ملف خطير
وقنبله موقوته في اي لحظه كيف يمكن
التعامل معها انسانيا دون يعني ربما
ملامسه خطوط امنيه حساسه جدا قد تهدد
لبنان
بالواقع هذا يتطلب امكانات هذه الامكانات
غير متوفره في يد الدوله اللبنانيه بصراحه
شديده حتى نكون واقعيين الامم المتحده
والمجتمع الدولي
اقر العديد من يعني المرات في العديد من
المرات دفع اموال للبنان ولكن هذه الاموال
لم تصل والمساعدات لم يصل الا النذر
القليل منها لذلك اقول بان ه هذه المخيمات
سوف تفجر بؤرا لان الفقر والحاجه والعوز
كل هذه امور تؤدي الى المزيد من المشاكل
لذلك قلت ان المشكله خطيره وليس لها حل
واعتقد انه لا بد من النظر الى هذه
المساله بكثير من الانتباه والخطوره في
نفس الوقت السيد عماد الحوت كيف يمكن
التعامل مع ملف اللاجئين بشكل انسان وفي
نفس الوقت تجنب ان تصبح هذه المخيمات بؤره
لما يسمى الارهاب يتهدد جميع يعني مكونات
الشعب اللبناني وليس لربما فئه دون
اخرى يعني اولا اعطاء الانطباع بانه هناك
استحاله للتعامل مع هذه الازمه وهي ازمه
حقيقيه يعني هذا يعني انطباع خاطئ احن منذ
بدايه الازمه طلبنا ان يكون هناك مخيمات
منظمه لهؤلاء اللاجئين حتى لا يكون وجودهم
على الارض اللبنانيه وج عشوائي وان تكون
هذه المخيمات تسهل العمل الانساني وقد
اشترطت المؤسسات الدوليه وجود هذه
المخيمات حتى تستمر بالمساعدات لانها تسهل
عليها هذه الاجراءات وان تكون هذه
المخيمات امنيا بعهده القوى الامنيه
اللبنانيه سواء الجيش اللبناني او القوى
الامنيه الاخرى ولنا تجارب فعليا الان في
عدد من المخيمات موجوده على الاراضي
اللبنانيه والجيش يدخل بشكل دوري يعني
يفتش وينظم امنيا الواقع الامني بهذه
الطريقه نستطيع نع ان
نحتوي القدره على المساعده الانسانيه
وبنفس الوقت نقلل من اي ارباك امني
المشكله انه هناك فريق من اللبنانيين يرفض
ان يسمح للدوله اللبنانيه ان تنطلق باتجاه
تنفيذ هذه المخيمات حتى نصل الى ما وصلنا
اليه في عرسال اليوم وانا اقول انه لا
يريد تنظيم وجود السوريين في لبنان هذا
الوجود المؤقت حتى يستطيع ان يتلاعب بهذا
الوجود لنصل الى حالات من التوتر كالتي
تشاهدها عرسال اليوم شكرا شكرا لك السيد
عماد الحوت النائب في البرلمان اللبناني
عن جماعه الاسلاميه كما نشكر ضيفنا السيد
واصف عواض الكاتب الباحث السياسي من بيروت
ونشكر عميد الياس حنا الخبير في شؤون
العسكريه والاستراتيجيه الذي رفقنا فيق
الجزء الاول من هذه الحلقه شكرا لمتابعتكم
والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله
وبركاته
ه